Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. Stalingrad is burned down. I would have to write too much if I wanted to describe it.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如果您想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先收听节目系列以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如果您想收听独家加更节目、抢先体验、无广告广播并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您在使用 Apple Podcasts 应用，只需点击几下即可在应用内订阅。斯大林格勒被焚为废墟。如果要描述它，我得写太多东西了。
Stalingrad is burned down. Stalingrad is in ashes. It is dead. People are in basements. Everything is burned out. The hot walls of the buildings are like the bodies of people who have died in the terrible heat and haven't gone cold yet. Huge buildings, memorials, public gardens, signs cross here. Heaps of wires, a cat sleeping on a windowsill, flowers and grass in flowerpots. A wooden pavilion where they sold fizzy water is standing miraculously intact among thousands of huge stone buildings burned and half destroyed.
斯大林格勒被焚为废墟。斯大林格勒化为灰烬。它死去了。人们躲在地窖里。一切都被烧毁了。建筑物滚烫的墙壁，就像在酷热中死去、体温尚未冷却的人类的尸体。巨大的建筑物、纪念碑、公共花园、十字路口指示牌。成堆的电线、窗台上睡觉的猫、花盆里的花草。在数千栋被烧毁和半毁的巨型石质建筑中，奇迹般地耸立着一座出售汽水的木制凉亭。
It is like Pompeii, seized by disaster on a day when everything was flourishing. The city has died after much suffering and looks like the face of a dead man who was suffering from a lethal disease and finally has found eternal peace. Bombing again. Bombing of the dead city. So that was Vasily Grossman, the great Russian war correspondent and novelist writing in his journal about the Battle of Stalingrad in 1942. And Tom Holland, he compares it to Pompeii. And I guess Stalingrad is a little bit like Pompeii in the sense that it's a sort of byword for disaster. Obviously, man-made, not natural. But it's also one of those words, one of those place names that just carries this electric charge.
它就像庞贝古城，在万物繁茂的一天遭遇了灾难。这座城市历经无数苦难后消亡了，看起来就像一个死者的面容，他曾饱受致命疾病的折磨，最终找到了永恒的平静。再次轰炸。对死城的轰炸。以上是瓦西里·格罗斯曼（Vasily Grossman）的言论，这位伟大的俄罗斯战地记者兼小说家在日记中记录了1942年的斯大林格勒战役。汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland）将其与庞贝古城进行比较。我想斯大林格勒在某种程度上确实有点像庞贝，因为它是灾难的代名词。显然，这是人为的，而不是自然的。但它也是那种带有这种强烈电荷的词汇、那种地名之一。
So even if you don't know the details of the battle, it sort of represents evil and destruction and horror and bloodshed, probably more than almost any other place on earth except that the thing about pompeii it's buried and so the signs of life are preserved and the fabric of the city is preserved whereas the thing about stalingrad is that it's completely flattened so perhaps a closer analogy if you're looking to ancient history would be carthage after the Romans have captured it or Jerusalem after the Romans have captured it. Stalingrad has become kind of shorthand, hasn't it, for the brutality of modern war. And of course, it's also very much in the new people sorts at the moment because it's the archetype of urban warfare, of modern urban warfare, the idea of fighting house by house, street by street.
因此，即使你不知道战役的细节，它在某种程度上也代表了邪恶、毁灭、恐怖和流血，可能比地球上几乎任何其他地方都要严重，只不过庞贝古城的特别之处在于它被埋藏了，因此生命的迹象得以保存，城市的结构得以保存，而斯大林格勒的特别之处在于它被彻底夷为平地，所以如果你在古代历史中寻找一个更贴切的类比，那可能是罗马人攻陷后的迦太基，或者罗马人攻陷后的耶路撒冷。斯大林格勒已经成为现代战争残酷性的某种简称，不是吗？当然，它现在也非常符合人们的眼光，因为它是城市战、现代城市战的原型，也就是逐屋、逐街战斗的理念。
And that, of course, is what's going on in Ukraine at the moment. So Putin is massively inspired by the example of the Red Army in the Second World War. But one of the ironies is that it's Mariupol that is, you know, the new Stalingrad. And what does that make the Red Army? Makes them the Nazis. So a good time I think to be doing this topic. Absolutely and listeners may remember that we did a podcast about the Berlin Wall with Ian McGregor who'd written a book about Checkpoint Charlie and we're welcoming Ian back today on a similarly, Ian you specialise in these very bleak and grim subjects clearly. Yes but I'm not a grim and bleak person. I do try to find the light
当然，这也是目前乌克兰正在发生的事情。因此，普京深受第二次世界大战中红军榜样的启发。但其中一个讽刺之处在于，马里乌波尔才是那个“新斯大林格勒”。那这把红军置于何地？把他们变成了纳粹。所以我觉得现在探讨这个话题是个好时机。当然，听众可能还记得，我们曾与伊恩·麦格雷戈（Ian McGregor）一起制作过一期关于柏林墙的播客，他写过一本关于查理检查站的书。今天我们很高兴伊恩再次做客，讨论一个同样……伊恩，显然你专门研究这些非常凄凉和残酷的主题。是的，但我并不是一个凄凉和残酷的人。我确实试图在
in these stories. Yes, my background in history and publishing history has predominantly been Eastern Europe, so especially World War I and definitely World War II. So with my publishing head on, I've pretty much published the majority of books on all the major events on the eastern front and in your new book i mean it's it's full of new material but people may be surprised to learn that there's still new stuff to be found about something that's as as written about as starling grad so in what sense is there still stuff to find well it's just trying to drill especially on the obviously on the on the Red Army side, which we'll dig deeper into as we talk. It's making sure that you can actually find original voices that are actually giving you a proper, accurate insight into the fighting, the casualties, the morale, maybe failures in discipline, as well as obviously bravery and who did what to whom and when and who are the real heroes. That's the core of my new book anyway is I knew the story
这些故事中寻找光明。是的，我的历史背景和出版历史主要集中在东欧，尤其是第一次世界大战，绝对还有第二次世界大战。所以带着我的出版编辑头脑，东线所有重大事件的大部分书籍基本上都由我出版了。在你的新书里——我是说，里面充满了全新材料——但人们可能会惊讶地发现，关于像斯大林格勒这样被写了无数遍的题材，竟然还能找到新东西。那么，在什么意义上还有东西可找呢？好吧，这只是试图深入挖掘，尤其是显然在红军这一侧，我们稍后在谈话中会深入探讨。这是为了确保你能真正找到能够对战斗、伤亡、士气、纪律方面的失败，以及显而易见的英勇行为、谁对谁做了什么、何时发生以及谁才是真正的英雄，给出恰当、准确见解的原始声音。这就是我新书的核心所在，无论如何，我知道这个故事
of what I wanted to say. I didn't want to do a kind of overall strategic narrative of the battle. As you said, that's been done many times. The world doesn't need another book like that. What I wanted to do was what I do in my publishing is I try and find new voices that tell it, give a different angle, give fresh insights and can sometimes, as I hope I've done in this book, overturn accepted tropes and myths about what is arguably the greatest military battle in terms of combatants, damage, casualties, et cetera, et cetera. So that's what it was about. And yeah, I mean, I was lucky and I emphasize lucky to,
我想讲述的内容。我不想做那种关于这场战役的整体战略叙事。正如你所说，这已经做过很多次了。世界不需要另一本这样的书。我想做的是我在出版工作中一直在做的事：我尝试寻找新的声音来讲述它，提供一个不同的角度，带来新鲜的见解，并且有时能够——正如我希望在这本书中所做的那样——颠覆关于这场可以说是作战人员、破坏、伤亡等各方面最伟大的军事战役的既定套路和神话。这就是这本书的意义所在。是的，我的意思是，我很幸运，我强调是幸运，
I went to Russia in the winter of 2019 during lockdown, got a special invitation from the director of the Panorama Museum on Volgograd. And I didn't know it at the time but i discovered it when i was there i was there for nine days and when i was sitting in the archive for five days uh all the material that i was reading no no one's looked at since the 1950s and 2019 quite a lot has intervened since 2019 that would make researching in russia quite difficult yeah absolutely so maybe we'll come to that and maybe we'll come to,
我于2019年冬天在封锁期间去了俄罗斯，得到了伏尔加格勒全景博物馆馆长的特别邀请。当时我并不知道，但当我在那里时我发现了这一点，我在那里待了九天，当我连续五天坐在档案馆里时……呃，我阅读的所有材料，自20世纪50年代以来就没人看过了。而2019年之后，发生了相当多的干预，这使得在俄罗斯进行研究变得相当困难。是的，绝对是。所以也许我们会谈到这一点，也许我们会谈到，
because obviously one of the, you talked about the myths and most of the myths have been generated by the Soviet Union and now by Russia. So obviously there is a kind of political sensitivity to them that's perhaps sharper than it might otherwise have been. But first of all, we, so we did an episode with my brother, actually, a couple of months ago on Operation Barbarossa. So people who want the kind of the full background to the Nazi invasion of Russia do listen to that. But Ian, could you just,
因为很显然，其中一个……你谈到了神话，而大多数神话都是由苏联生成，现在又由俄罗斯生成的。所以显然，这里有一种政治敏感性，可能比平时更加尖锐。但首先，我们……所以几个月前我们实际上和我弟弟制作了一期关于巴巴罗萨行动的播客，所以想要了解纳粹入侵俄罗斯完整背景的人一定要去听那一期。不过伊恩，你能简单地，
just, just give us a quick reminder of how Operation Barbarossa pans out and what then happens after Operation Barbarossa ends that takes us up to Stalingrad? Well, as James has eloquently described, Barbarossa was obviously Hitler's and the German armed forces' great gamble to what they thought would be a quick victory over an enormous opponent of the Red Army. Three army groups, over 3 million Axis forces, predominantly German, obviously, with serious armoured columns, invaded the Soviet Union, going north, centre and south. In a great invasion, the ultimate aim was to destroy the Red Army in that first summer's campaign from June 1941 onwards. As Hitler obviously said and was confident of, he just had to kick the door in of what he perceived to be a rotten Bolshevist edifice and it would collapse. But as the summer months progressed and going in towards the wintertime, their early successes where they're
简单地为我们快速回顾一下巴巴罗萨行动是如何展开的，以及在巴巴罗萨行动结束后发生了什么，从而把我们带入斯大林格勒战役？嗯，正如詹姆斯雄辩地描述的那样，巴巴罗萨显然是希特勒和德国武装力量的一场大赌博，他们原以为对红军这样一个庞大的对手能取得速胜。三个集团军，超过三百万轴心国军队——显然主要是德国人，配有强大的装甲纵队——从1941年6月开始的头年夏天的大规模入侵中，入侵了苏联，分北、中、南三路推进。这场大入侵的最终目标是在那年夏天的第一场战役中消灭红军。正如希特勒显然说过并且深信不疑的那样，他只需要踢开他所认为的已经腐朽的布尔什维克大厦的门，它就会倒塌。但随着夏日过去并步入冬季，他们早期的成功——当时他们的机械化纵队
forging forward hundreds of kilometers with their motorized columns was that they were being met by serious and heavy and fierce and almost suicidal in places Soviet Red Army resistance to where by the time of winter 1941, when they're outside the gates of Moscow, they suffered hundreds of thousands of casualties and hundreds and thousands of destroyed or damaged vehicles, a huge dent in their ability to fight. Magnified by the fact that they hadn't taken into account that Stalin would be able to move mass fresh divisions from the East based in Siberia that were potentially guarding against a future attack by Japan. Once that fear was obviously erased because
向前推进了数百公里——遭到了苏联红军严厉、猛烈、凶猛且在某些地方近乎自杀式的抵抗。到了1941年冬天，当他们兵临莫斯科城下时，他们已经遭受了数十万的伤亡，以及数十万辆被摧毁或损坏的车辆，其作战能力受到了沉重的打击。这一情况因以下事实而加剧：他们没有把斯大林能够从东部西伯利亚（原本可能防范日本未来进攻）调集大批生力军这一点考虑在内。一旦这种担忧显然被消除了——
the Japanese were obviously going to attack Pearl Harbor and the American fleet, he moved these fresh divisions over and implemented a very surprising for the Germans counterattack, which did drive them back from the by the spring of 1942, they were in a slight predicament. They'd had a serious pushback from the Red Army. The Red Army wasn't destroyed. Hitler had saved the day, I suppose, in the fact that he'd given some backbone to his local commanders who wanted to retreat even further and set up a more workable defensive line. They'd held on into the territory. They were deep inside Russian territory.
因为日本人显然要袭击珍珠港和美国舰队——他把这些生力军调了过来，并实施了令德国人感到非常意外的反击，确实将他们击退了。到了1942年春天，他们陷入了一种轻微的困境。他们受到了红军的反击。红军并没有被消灭。我想，希特勒拯救了局面，因为他给那些想要进一步撤退并建立更具操作性的防御线的前方指挥官们注入了一些骨气。他们坚守在领土上。他们深入俄罗斯领土。
They surrounded Leningrad in the north. They were still only about 120 kilometers away from Moscow, the capital. And in the south, they still held vast areas of the Ukraine. So by the spring, it was what do we do next on the German side? But equally, from Stalin's perspective, they were busy really rushing together fresh troops. Millions of Russians were now forming up into fresh armies that were being trained and organized in the East, well out of sight of any kind of German reconnaissance planes. They had no idea that such armies still existed or were coming onto line.
他们在北部包围了列宁格勒。距离首都莫斯科仍然只有大约120公里。而在南部，他们依然控制着乌克兰的大片地区。所以在春天，德国方面面临的问题是：我们接下来该做什么？但同样，从斯大林的视角来看，他们正在忙于匆忙拼凑生力军。数百万俄罗斯人现在正编入新的军队，在远离任何德国侦察机视线的东部进行训练和组织。他们根本不知道这样的军队依然存在或正在加入战线。
So for Hitler, as a case of, right, I've got the Ukrainian wheat. What do I need now? Especially by the spring of 1942, he's already declared war on the United States. He knows he's into a very long strategic struggle to even maintain what he's got. So he now thinks, I need Caucasian oil. Because all he has is oil from Romania. Romanian oil could keep them supplied to a degree, but to fight what he knew would now be a prolonged war,
所以对希特勒来说，这是一个“对，我得到了乌克兰的小麦，我现在还需要什么？”的问题。特别是在1942年春天，他已经向美国宣战。他知道自己陷入了一场漫长的战略斗争中，甚至连维持现状都成问题。所以他现在认为：“我需要高加索的石油。”因为他所有的只有来自罗马尼亚的石油。罗马尼亚的石油在某种程度上可以维持供应，但为了打一场他现在知道将会是一场漫长战争的战役，
Germany was still not committed to a total war industry, unlike the Soviets, obviously. Their factories were literally pell-mell pouring out armaments and materiel to fight this war, whereas Germany hadn't done that just yet. So yes, as you said, they were relying heavily on Romanian oil and they had other theatres to worry about. So they were in North Africa as well. That needed oil to carry on. So there was multiple fronts. There was multiple concerns. And just on that drive for Caucasian oil, in a lot of the sort of historiography,
德国当时仍未像苏联那样全力投入总体战工业。显然，苏联的工厂正马力全开地生产武器和物资来打这场战争，而德国当时还没有做到这一点。所以是的，正如你所说，他们严重依赖罗马尼亚的石油，而且他们还有其他战场需要担心。所以他们也在北非。那需要石油才能继续运转。因此有多个战线，有多种担忧。关于对高加索石油的追逐，在许多历史著作中，
and almost in what you might call the kind of folk historiography, so in what people vaguely think about the Second World War, Hitler's drive to Stalingrad is seen as this sort of suicidal disaster. But on the face of it, you could say that if you're in that position in spring 1942, I mean, you really do need that oil. And the place to get it is the Caucasus. If you get there, I mean, if it had worked out, it would look like the right decision, wouldn't it? Or do you think it never would have worked out this plan? I would argue the same as James did when he was talking to Barbarossa with you guys. They hadn't got, from the research I've done anyway, they hadn't actually
几乎在你可以称之为民间历史学的东西中，也就是人们对第二次世界大战的模糊印象中，希特勒向斯大林格勒的推进被视为一种自杀式的灾难。但表面上看，你可以说如果你处于1942年春天的那个位置，我的意思是，你确实需要那些石油。而获取它的地方就是高加索。如果你到了那里，我的意思是，如果成功了，这看起来会是一个正确的决定，不是吗？还是说你认为这个计划根本不可能成功？我会持有与詹姆斯和你讨论巴巴罗萨时相同的观点。根据我所做的研究，他们实际上并没有
set in plan a process to what would they do when they captured these oil fields. The Red Army is not just going to say, there you go, guys, take our oil refineries in Mykop and Grozny. They would obviously destroy them. But there was never a plan in place for specific units. I think there was one battalion at the time, but there was never a large-scale operation to say, once we have these refineries, it will take some time to get them back online, and then even more time to figure out how are we going to get this oil back to where it needs to be
制定计划来确定当他们占领这些油田时该怎么做。红军不会只是说：“给你们，伙计们，拿去吧，这是我们在迈科普和格罗兹尼的炼油厂。”他们显然会摧毁它们。但从来没有为特定部队制定过相应的计划。我想当时有一个营，但从来没有大规模的行动说：一旦我们拥有了这些炼油厂，将它们重新投入运行需要一些时间，而要弄清楚我们如何将这些石油运回我们占领区所需的地方，无论是通过陆路，则需要更多的时间。
in our occupied territories, whether by land. So if it's going by train, as we've talked about before, the Russian rail gauge was different to the rest of Western Europe. That would have to be changed. You're on a logistic line of over 1,500 miles, if not 2,000 miles. That would be under attack at some point. So how do you get it safely back? If you go by sea, the Black Sea is still not safe for German shipping, as was proven even with trying to get across that short gap of the Mediterranean to feed Rommel's Africa core. That was proving impossible to get them oil supplied.
因此，如果是通过火车运输，正如我们之前讨论过的，俄罗斯的铁路轨距与西欧其他地方不同。那必须改变。你的后勤补给线超过1500英里，甚至2000英里。这些线路在某个时候会遭到攻击。那么你如何安全地将它们运回去？如果走海路，黑海对于德国船运来说仍然不安全，正如即使试图穿过地中海的那小段间隙去给隆美尔的非洲军团提供补给时所证明的那样。事实证明，为他们供应石油是不可能的。
So it's one thing having the scope to think that's what we need to do. It's very good. But if you haven't got the actual plan in place once your army have conquered the land, then it's a different kettle of fish, really. I mean, what I get from your book is that certainly Hitler's enemies were nervous about this. So people in Britain are saying, oh, my God, he'll seize these oil fields and he'll be able to get the Middle East. He'll be able to invade India or whatever. So they're nervous of it. And I guess that Hitler has three targets, doesn't he? He has Leningrad and the capture of Leningrad would obviously be a great blow. Capture of Moscow, that would be a great blow as well. I mean,
所以，有这种认为那是我们需要做的事的宏图是一回事。这很好。但一旦你的军队征服了土地，如果你没有制定实际的计划，那就完全是另一回事了。我的意思是，从你的书中我了解到，希特勒的敌人对此无疑感到紧张。因此，英国的人们在说：“哦，天哪，他会占领这些油田，他将能够进入中东。他将能够入侵印度或诸如此类的事情。”所以他们对此感到紧张。我猜希特勒有三个目标，对吧？他有列宁格勒，占领列宁格勒显然是一个巨大的打击。占领莫斯科，那也将是一个巨大的打击。我的意思是，
it does seem reasonable to say that even more important than these two great cities is the opportunity to get oil. Because even if they even if the Red Army had blown up the oil fields, surely the Nazis would be able to get them back up and operating fairly quickly. And if they're thinking in terms of, you know, a war that's going to last years and years, then, you know, a few months. Yeah. Well, I was going to say know and also the major fact is they're denying this oil to the red army yeah there's that as well yeah yeah their heavy industry that they pushed which was an amazing feat to do they relocated their their heavy industry to the east of the ural mountains and kept it safe there so that and they they rebuilt their armaments uh infrastructure there uh and that would take some time to come online, which explains the weaknesses in the response to defend the Caucasus
说获取石油的机会甚至比这两座伟大的城市更重要，这似乎是合理的。因为即使他们——即使红军炸毁了油田，纳粹肯定也能在相当短的时间内将其修复并重新投入运营？如果他们从长远考虑——比如一场将持续数年之久的战争——那么，几个月的时间……是的。嗯，我要说的是，还有一个主要事实是，他们正在剥夺红军的这些石油。是的，还有这一点。是的，是的，他们推进的重工业——这是一个了不起的壮举，他们将重工业搬迁到了乌拉尔山脉以东并在那里确保了安全。因此，他们在那里的武器基础设施得到了重建——
and the road to Stalingrad that summer. But you're right. I mean, I see that the capture of Leningrad, I see, is fairly cosmetic. The capture of Moscow, definitely, that would be a huge propaganda boost. But it makes sense to go south. I don't disagree with that because strategically, that's be a huge propaganda boost. But it makes sense to go south. I don't disagree with that because strategically, that's what you want to do. And they knew that the bulk of whatever Red Army forces Stalin still had, and maybe they did know he must have some fresh forces coming online, they would be protecting the capital.
这需要一段时间才能投入运营，这也解释了当年夏天防守高加索和通往斯大林格勒的道路时反应的薄弱。但你是对的。我的意思是，我认为攻占列宁格勒基本上只具有象征意义。攻占莫斯科绝对会带来巨大的宣传提振。但向南进发是有道理的。我对此并不否认，因为从战略上讲，那会带来巨大的宣传提振。但向南进发是有道理的。我对此并不否认，因为从战略上讲，这就是你想做的事。而且他们知道，斯大林手头拥有的任何红军主力部队——也许他们确实知道他肯定有一些生力军即将加入战线——都会用来保卫首都。
So if they tried to attack Moscow again, they were in for a huge bloody struggle and they would incur probably the same amount of casualties they had the previous summer in 1941. So it made sense. They had already the bridgeheads they needed in the Ukraine outside of Kursk to have the jump-off points to go east towards the Volga. And once you've secured the flank, then you would push south to take over the Caucasus. And that operation, so it's called Case Blue. So when you look at the chronology, they launched at the end of June 1942.
因此，如果他们试图再次进攻莫斯科，他们将面临一场极其血腥的斗争，并且可能会遭受与前一年（1941年夏天）大致相同的伤亡。所以向南进发是有道理的。他们已经在库尔斯克以外的乌克兰拥有了所需的桥头堡，作为向东进发至伏尔加河的跳板。一旦确保了侧翼的安全，他们就会向南推进以接管高加索。那项行动被称为“蓝色方案”。所以当你查看时间表时，他们在1942年6月底发动了进攻。
They sort of charge across the steppes, don't they? I mean, I've read diaries of German officers saying they felt like they're kind of Teutonic Knights or something, or like Crusaders. It's sunny, it's summer, they can get food from the surrounding fields, all's going well. You look at the dates and the progress, I mean, they're capturing city after city. They get Rostov on dawn by the end of July. They they get my cop with this oil fields at the beginning of august and then sort of stalingrad comes into view and stalingrad obviously well there are all kinds of um things to say about why why it's stalingrad why it's because on the face of it, it might seem a sideshow. But Ian, so Stalingrad originates Saritsyn.
他们可以说是冲过了草原，不是吗？我的意思是，我读过德国军官的日记，他们说自己感觉像是某种日耳曼骑士，或者是十字军。天气晴朗，正值夏天，他们可以从周围的田野里获取食物，一切进展顺利。你看那些日期和进展，我的意思是，他们接连攻占了一座又一座城市。他们在7月底攻占了顿河畔罗斯托夫。他们在8月初攻占了拥有油田的迈科普，然后斯大林格勒进入了视野。显然，关于为什么是斯大林格勒，为什么是因为表面上看，它可能显得像是一个次要战场。但伊恩，斯大林格勒最初叫察里津。
Well, it had been around as a settlement since by the time of the Vikings. The Volga is over 3,000 kilometers long, goes from the top of beyond the north of Moscow all the way down, pours out to the Caspian Sea. There's like 500 tributaries and rivers that feed off it as well. So it is, you know, simplistically, it's the Mississippi to Russians, really. It's their great river. And so there were, there's obviously villages that turned into towns that, and then by the 20th century turned into cities stretching along the Volga. What made Saritsyn so vital was rail coming to it. I liken it quite a lot to what happened with the expansion of industry and cities in the Midwest of America,
嗯，早在维京人时代，这里就已经作为一个定居点存在了。伏尔加河长达3000多公里，从莫斯科以北的远方一路向下，注入里海。还有大约500条支流和河流汇入其中。所以，简单来说，它对俄罗斯人来说就是密西西比河，是他们伟大的河流。因此，那里显然有一些村庄演变成了城镇，然后到了20世纪演变成了沿伏尔加河延绵的城市。使察里津变得如此至关重要的原因是铁路的到来。我将其比作美国中西部工业和城市扩张中发生的事情，
like Chicago. So as soon as it became obvious logistically and topographically that Saritsyn, it had the river connection, but then they sit down the railway. It's surrounded by the steppe, as you say, where you're growing wheat. It just made sense that that would be one of the main places at that point at the top of the Caucasus that would be a big trading post. You've got other places like Saratov as well, which is a few hundred kilometers away, but that was one of the main places and that's how it grew but it really only exploded in growth uh from population wise as well as industry during the 20th century and obviously that was kick-started by the russian civil war well because i was amazed i was amazed to learn from your book that um star i should probably have known this but i didn't that that stalin had actually been besieged there himself yes and kind of made it during the Civil War and made it into a Red Verdun.
比如芝加哥。因此，一旦从后勤和地形上明显看出察里津既有河流连接，然后又铺设了铁路。正如你所说，它被种植小麦的草原环绕。这就顺理成章地成为高加索顶端的主要贸易站之一。你还有其他地方，比如几百公里外的萨拉托夫，但那是主要地点之一，这就是它的发展历程。不过，它在人口和工业方面真正爆发式增长是在20世纪，显然这由俄国内战拉开了序幕。因为我很惊讶，我很惊讶地从你的书中了解到，嗯，斯大林——我大概应该知道这一点，但我不知道——斯大林本人实际上曾在那里被围困过。是的，在内战期间，它变成了一个“红色凡尔登”。
And is that the reason why, and they hold out heroically and Stalin's a great hero and it's brilliant. And that's why they call it after him. They change it. Obviously, you can't call anything after the Tsars, you know, in communist Russia. But is that why it's specific to him?
这难道就是原因吗？他们进行了英勇的抵抗，斯大林是一位伟大的英雄，这太精彩了。这就是为什么他们用他的名字来命名它。他们更改了名字。显然，在共产主义俄罗斯，你不能用沙皇的名字来命名任何东西。但这难道就是为什么它是专门以他命名的原因吗？
It's the city of Stalin. Yeah, I mean, that's why he made his name as a leader of uh or you know one of the leaders in in the elite of the communist party uh i suppose he would rely upon that as some kind of he had the prowess of a general as well i mean he was parachuted in to again put backbone into the city it's's very similar, really. It was surrounded by the white armies that were marauding around the Caucasus, up and down the land, taking out villages and towns and cities. And Saracen was in danger. It changed hands several times. But Stalin was the one who,
这是斯大林的城市。是的，我的意思是，这就是他作为领导人之一，或者说共产党精英中的领导人之一而扬名立万的原因……我想他会依靠这一点来证明自己也具备将军的才干。我的意思是，他被空降到那里，再次为这座城市注入骨气，这其实非常相似。它被在高加索四处游荡、在各地制造破坏并夺取村庄、城镇和城市的白军所包围。察里津处于危险之中。它几次易手。但斯大林是那个，
I suppose, gave it the backbone to have the final defense, which is what it's famous for in 1920, fought off white occupation and saved it. But obviously, it only changed its name once he'd become leader in 1925. And again, that's a propaganda thing. But it was seen, the key thing is skipping forward a decade, once he was putting into place his five-year plans, Stalingrad then took on another dimension, and it would be seen as a shining example of what the Soviet system and the new economic policies could do by taking this small city and expanding it massively to be a huge industrial centre. So literally, it's a centre for tractor production, isn't it? I mean, I know that sounds like something from a Western stereotype, but that's really what they're doing, turning out thousands upon thousands of tractors. Yeah, backed up and paid for by American money,
我想，赋予它进行最后防御的骨气的人。这就是它在1920年闻名的原因——击退了白军的占领并拯救了它。但显然，只有当他在1925年成为领导人后，它才改名。这同样是一项宣传工作。但关键在于，快进十年，一旦他开始实施五年计划，斯大林格勒就展现出了另一个维度，它被视为苏联体制和新经济政策所能取得成就的光辉典范——通过将这座小城大规模扩建成一个巨大的工业中心。所以字面意思上，它是一个拖拉机生产中心，对吧？我的意思是，我知道这听起来像是西方刻板印象中的东西，但他们确实在大量生产成千上万台拖拉机。是的，由20年代末和30年代初的美国资金支持并支付，
investment in the late 20s and early 30s. The main factories where we see most of the fighting, which I'm sure we'll talk about, so the tractor factory, the barricaded weapons factory, and the steelworks, they were all financed by American money. So you've got, I think, about 400,000 people there in approximately by the end of the 1930s. Yeah, I was gonna say, it's about 450,000 lived there, the majority of which worked in the factory district to the north. So by the time of the Germans arriving, what they would have seen is a city that wasn't too deep as it went along to the river.
进行了投资。我们看到大部分战斗的主要工厂——我确信我们会讨论到这一点，也就是拖拉机厂、红巴里凯达武器厂和钢铁厂——全部都是由美国资金资助的。所以我想，到20世纪30年代末，那里大约有40万人口。是的，我是说，大约有45万人住在那里，其中大多数人在北部的工业区工作。因此，当德国人到达时，他们看到的是一座沿河方向并不太深的城市。
It was probably in the most dense place. It was probably five kilometers you had to travel through before you get to the Volga. But it was very long. It stretched along the river. It's kind of ribbon development. Yeah, it's about 35 kilometers long, possibly 40. Wow. It's like an enormous snake.
在人口最密集的地区，你可能必须穿行大约五公里才能到达伏尔加河。但它非常长。它沿着河流延伸。这是一种类似带状发展的形态。是的，它大约有35公里长，可能40公里。哇。它就像一条巨大的蛇。
Yes, indeed. Because in the south, you had the old part of the city, which is quite feudal. They're the famous shots you get as the Germans are going through the suburbs. You've got the wooden shacks and two, never usually more than two-story shacks that people lived in. In the center of the city, which again is where you have all the famous fighting house to house, that's where you had the modernisation with the lovely boulevards, parks, shops, apartment blocks for the parties and the elites, theatres, everything.
确实如此。因为在南部，有城市的旧城区，那里相当封建。当德国人穿过郊区时，你会看到那些著名的画面。那里有木屋，通常不超过两层，人们就住在里面。而在市中心——同样也是所有著名的巷战发生的地方——那里进行了现代化改造，有林荫大道、公园、商店、供党员和精英居住的公寓楼、剧院以及应有尽有。
And then the bulk of the city was the factory district in the north. And probably about 80% of the population were housed there uh in their settlements and again by the time you get into the third and final phase of the fight for stalingrad in the winter that's where the bulk of the the really heavy fighting was done right good so that is that's basically the geography sorted so um i think we should take a little break now uh and when we come back we we will discuss the Germans' motivation for basically starting you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
然后，城市的大部分是北部的工业区。大约80%的人口都住在那里以及他们的定居点里。同样，当你进入冬季斯大林格勒战役的第三阶段也是最后阶段时，那是真正最激烈的战斗发生的主体区域。好极了，所以地理情况基本上理清了；嗯，我想我们现在应该休息一下，等我们回来后，我们将讨论德国人发起这场战役的动机，基本上了解这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. So, Ian, one of the things I've always wondered, and it probably seems quite a basic question, is why was there a battle at Stalingrad at all? Because the Germans, it's not a prime target for them. They could ignore it, or they could bypass it, or they could just turn south once they've got to the Volga, or once they're approaching the Volga, they could turn south and head into the Caucasus and some people might argue that's kind of what they should have done is it because it's Stalin city and it's Hitler wants the psychological
欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。所以，伊恩，我一直想知道的一件事——这可能看起来是一个非常基本的问题——为什么会有一场斯大林格勒战役？因为对德国人来说，它并不是首要目标。他们可以忽略它，或者绕过它，或者一旦到达伏尔加河，或者一旦接近伏尔加河，他们就可以向南转向高加索。有些人可能会认为这正是他们应该做的。是因为它是斯大林的城市，希特勒想要获取占领它的心理
boost of of taking it or is it because of the industrial production and all that sort of stuff or is it also because because presumably up to this point the Germans haven't lost and so are they still convinced basically that they can do anything they like that they'll always be victorious well that that's the thing tom they hadn't lost but they stalled that that was the key thing so by the time the decisions made to we're going to take stalingrad uh and that's mid to late august uh by then the juggernauts of Case Blue was heavily stalled. They were bogged down by a myriad of things, which we'll take another podcast to talk about.
提振，还是因为工业生产以及所有这些乱七八糟的东西？或者也是因为——据推测在此之前德国人还没有输过，所以他们基本上仍然确信自己可以为所欲为，永远战无不胜？嗯，这就是关键所在，汤姆。他们没有输，但他们陷入了停滞，这才是关键。所以在决定我们要攻占斯大林格勒——那是在8月中旬到下旬——的时候，蓝色方案的庞大战争机器已经严重陷入停滞。他们被无数的事情缠身，我们需要另一期播客来谈论这些。
Did they need a victory then? Yes, it was purely last gasp's chance to retrieve something of what was a failed offensive, and Hitler knew that. But Hitler doesn't think it's failed, does he? He still thinks that victory is absolutely within their grasp. Oh, I think by mid-August to late-August, the feeling was in his headquarters that they're not making the headway they thought
那他们当时需要一场胜利吗？是的，这纯粹是最后关头企图挽救失败攻势的孤注一掷，希特勒心知肚明。但希特勒并不认为它失败了，不是吗？他仍然认为胜利绝对唾手可得。哦，我认为从8月中旬到8月下旬，他的总部有一种感觉：他们在迈科普和格罗兹尼方向上的进展
they would do towards Maikop and Grozny. Even though they've made a tremendous, I mean, they've covered hundreds of miles, again, as they did in a year earlier, but they've just got an incredibly unrealistic timetable. Exactly. Yeah. I mean, the phases, those four to five phases of what they do on specific times, whether capturing key transport connections like Rostov or Voronezh or getting to Grozny or Mykop, heading east to get past the Don Bridge, head towards the Volga. It was all done on a strict timetable.
没有他们预期的那么快。尽管他们取得了巨大的进展——我的意思是，他们跨越了数百英里，就像前一年一样——但他们只是制定了一个极其不切实际的时间表。完全正确。是的。我的意思是，在特定时间执行的那些四到五个阶段，无论是攻占像罗斯托夫或沃罗涅日这样的关键交通枢纽，还是到达格罗兹尼或迈科普，向东进发越过顿河大桥，前往伏尔加河。这一切都是在严格的时间表下进行的。
And a bit like Barbarossa, they'd launched it a little bit too late because they were preoccupied with clearing up the Crimea as well. And once they'd done that and they'd secured their flank on the western side, then it was time to go. But yeah, it had run into problems that Barbarossa ran into, as in logistical problems, lack of fuel. There was many times as the panzers, as you were saying about the panzers heading south and heading east through the steppe, there was plenty of times they had to actually stand in the road and wait for resupply.
有点像巴巴罗萨，他们发起得稍微有点晚，因为他们还忙于清理克里米亚。一旦他们完成了这一点并确保了西侧侧翼的安全，就可以出发了。但是的，它遇到了巴巴罗萨遇到的问题，比如后勤问题、缺乏燃料。正如你所说，当装甲部队向南、向东穿过草原时，有很多次他们不得不实际上停在路上等待补给。
If it hadn't been for the Luftwaffe, I mean, the Luftwaffe going down south into the Caucasus, the Luftwaffe was supplying 200 million tons of fuel just to keep them going because there was no logistical connection. The railheads weren't working and the trucks are backed up behind the panzer columns. Well, Ian, in the last episode, Dominic disgraced himself by scoffing at the very idea that trucks could be interesting. I don't doubt that they're important i just question whether they're interesting well they are well they're interesting to the degree that essentially it's not just about our men is it it's about the chains of supply it's always about the chains it's always about the chains of trucks and and the different gauges and all that kind of stuff which i know that dominic is absolutely fascinated by you're talking about
如果不是因为空军——我的意思是，前往高加索南部的空军为了维持他们的运转，运送了两亿吨燃料，因为没有后勤连接。铁路终点站无法运作，卡车在装甲纵队后面排起了长队。好吧，伊恩，在上期节目中，多米尼克对“卡车可能很有趣”这种想法嗤之以鼻，从而让自己丢脸了。我不怀疑它们很重要，我只是质疑它们是否有趣。它们当然有趣，有趣到本质上这不仅关乎人，对吧？这关乎补给链。这永远关乎补给链，永远关乎卡车站、不同的轨距以及所有诸如此类的事情。我知道多米尼克对此绝对着迷。既然你谈到
gauges let me squash you right then let's talk about some human beings so we're talking about the sixth army uh in that's the the german sixth army and the commander um who's sort of gone down in history as this sort of terrible failure loser yeah it's a great loser which may be a little bit harsh is um friedrich paulus so he's not meant to be the commander is he because reichenau who i's not meant to be the commander, is he? Because Reichenau, who I think was meant to be the commander, has died. I can't remember how he's died. Is it von Reichenau? Yeah.
轨距，那我得立刻打断你。让我们来谈谈人类吧。我们正在谈论第六集团军——那是德国第六集团军——以及在历史上被视为一个可怕失败者的指挥官……是的，一个伟大的失败者，这可能有点过于严厉了，他就是弗里德里希·保卢斯（Friedrich Paulus）。所以他本不应该成为指挥官，对吧？因为赖歇瑙——我记得本该是他的那个指挥官——去世了。我不记得他是怎么死的了。是冯·赖歇瑙吗？是的。
Yes. He has a stroke, doesn't he? He comes in for a run and has a stroke. It's a warning against going for too many runs. Yeah. He's a jogging martyr. But was he a more effective commander than Paulus? So might things have been different had he not had his stroke? Yeah. He was much more well he was i mean it's chalk and cheese he was a much more effective
他中风了，不是吗？他去跑步然后中风了。这是一个不要跑太多步的警示。是的，他是慢跑烈士。但他比保卢斯更具作战才能吗？如果他没有中风，事情会有所不同吗？是的，他好得多……我的意思是，这简直是天壤之别，他是一个更有效的
combat commander frontline combat commander he's your man yeah i'd want him every single sunday uh whereas paulus was a very very effective planner and staff operator and that's where he'd made his reputation he's he'd never really been where he hadn't been a combat leader he'd never led anything uh more than a division uh and he'd been he'd been in that he'd he'd been one of the heads of the group that war-gamed Barbarossa before Barbarossa actually commenced in June 41. Was that the war game where they said this is going to be hopeless we haven't got hope exactly they got told to go away and come up with a new plan exactly right so so does he think that there's no hope of capturing stalingrad i mean is he a pessimist about this or what's he thinking well he he's not going to go against uh the order but do we know what what he is thinking when so so he comes he's at the head of the sixth army
前线战斗指挥官。他就是你要找的人。是的，我每个星期天都想要他。而保卢斯是一个非常非常高效的参谋人员和计划制定者，他的名声就是这么来的。他从未真正……他从来不是一个战斗领袖。他从未领导过任何超过一个师的部队。而且他曾是……他曾是策划巴巴罗萨行动的核心小组成员之一，该小组在1941年6月巴巴罗萨正式开始前进行了兵棋推演。那是那场兵棋推演吗？他们在推演中说这毫无希望，我们根本没有……完全正确，他们被告知走开并拿出一个新计划。完全正确。所以保卢斯认为攻占斯大林格勒毫无希望吗？我的意思是，他对此持悲观态度，还是他在想什么？好吧，他不会违抗命令，
they arrive at stalingrad this massive great kind of ribbon development along the Volga. Is it his decision to go in? Is it Hitler's decision? If it's Hitler's, is Paulus thinking this is terrible, we're going to lose? Or does he think, yeah, we're going to storm this because we're the Germans? What's the state of his opinion? And what's the morale of the 6th Army generally? Well, the key thing to remember is it wasn't a waltz for them. Yes, they'd had massive early successes in the summer, but the Russians, as they did the previous year where they were fighting for every inch of ground, they were retreating in a uniformed way. And obviously, especially in the Caucasus, implementing a scorched earth policy, leaving nothing for the Germans. Hitler, by 23rd of July, Hitler was feeling super confident because they couldn't find these huge forces he suspected were out there that they wanted to, as usual, encircle and destroy. He's thinking, well, the Red Army's finished. It's on the brink of collapse. I know what I can do. I can now split Army Group South into two subunits.
但我们知道他在想什么吗？当他来到这里——他率领第六集团军抵达斯大林格勒，这座沿伏尔加河延绵的巨大带状城市。这是他的决定还是希特勒的决定？如果是希特勒的，保卢斯会觉得这太可怕了，我们会输吗？还是他觉得：是的，我们会冲进去，因为我们是德国人？他的观点是什么？第六集团军的整体士气如何？好吧，需要记住的关键是，对他们来说这不是一场轻松的华尔兹。是的，他们在夏天取得了巨大的早期成功，但苏联人就像前一年为每一英寸土地战斗时一样，正在进行有组织地撤退。显然，特别是在高加索地区，他们实行了焦土政策，什么都不给德国人留下。到7月23日，希特勒感到超级自信，因为他们找不到他所怀疑的那些庞大部队——一如既往地，他们想包围并消灭这些部队。他在想，好吧，红军完了。它处于崩溃的边缘。我知道我能做什么。我现在可以把南方集团军群拆分为两个子单位。
When you say Army Group South, I don't really know what they are. How many people are they? Well, Army Group South was the force that had been put together by Hitler at the start of the summer campaigning that was going to implement Case Blue. It's one and a half million men. So what proportion of that is of the entire army on the Eastern Front? Is that about half of it? Yeah, I'd say just under half. And he'd stripped various units along the whole length of the line,
当你提到南方集团军群时，我其实不知道它们是什么。它们有多少人？嗯，南方集团军群是希特勒在夏季战役开始时组建的部队，旨在实施“蓝色方案”。它有一百五十万人。那么这占东线整个军队的比例是多少？大概是一半左右吗？是的，我想略低于一半。而且他从整条战线的各个单位抽调了兵力——
north to centre, to reinforce south for this offensive. And that's not just men, but that's aircraft and armour. So they were giving the bulk of everything. They tied down the Russians in the centre. And obviously they're still surrounding Leningrad, so the Russians are still busy trying to make sure they can try and free the city there. But everything was orientated for this. But by 23rd of July, weeks into Case Blue being underway, they're believing at Hitler's headquarters that success is on the brink, that they could do this because it seems that there is no Red Army to capture because they're collapsing. So flushed with this overconfidence, he then decides, I'm going to split the offensive
从北到中——来增援南方的这次攻势。这不仅是人员，还有飞机和装甲部队。所以他们把绝大部分资源都投了进去。他们把苏联人牵制在中心。显然他们仍在包围列宁格勒，所以苏联人仍然忙于确保他们能够试图解放那里的城市。但一切都是为了这个目标而部署的。然而到7月23日，“蓝色方案”进行数周后，希特勒的总部认为成功就在眼前，他们可以做到这一点，因为似乎根本没有红军可以消灭，因为他们在崩溃。因此，在过度自信的冲昏头脑下，他随后决定将攻势
in two. Army Group A will now push on down to the Caucasus and capture Grozny and Mykov. And simultaneously, and that's the key thing, instead of consecutively, as we talked about, they should do it phase by phase sensibly. said, simultaneously, Army Group B will push east and secure the Volga, stop river traffic. At the time, it wasn't said that they would need to capture the city. It was literally just to occupy the high grounds and the riverbanks around the city and just stop traffic. But doing that, that's where, to get back to my point about it wasn't an easy ride, by the time this was underway, that's when Paulus and the 6th Army, an Army Group B that he belonged to, started to really, really meet fierce resistance,
一分为二。A集团军群现在将向下推进到高加索并攻占格罗兹尼和迈科普。同时——这是关键所在——B集团军群没有像我们之前讨论的那样明智地按部就班分阶段推进，而是同时向东推进并控制伏尔加河，切断河流交通。当时并没有说他们需要攻占这座城市。字面意思仅仅是占领该市周围的高地和河岸，切断交通。但这样做——为了回到我刚才说的这不是一次轻松的旅程——正是在进行这项工作时，保卢斯和他所属的第六集团军以及B集团军群，才开始真正、真正地遇到激烈的抵抗。
suicidal resistance, like they had the summer before, where the Russians were now determined to not yield any more ground because stalingrad's behind them and ian that's partly because stalin has issued an order not one step back so the russians i mean they literally can't they may get shot if they if they step back so that's order 227 and that's 28th of july uh and that was uh funnily enough, it wasn't ever put out by any of the Soviet media or the Red Army media. What it was done was printed out on pamphlets and it was read out to the troops, officers and troops. And predominantly it was aimed more at the officer class because it was saying that you guys need to show more backbone and we are not retreating any further and any key installations will be held
自杀式的抵抗，就像他们前一个夏天那样，俄国人现在下定决心不再让出哪怕一寸土地，因为斯大林格勒就在他们身后。部分原因是因为斯大林下达了“绝不退缩”的命令，所以俄国人——我的意思是，他们字面意义上真的不能退缩，如果他们退缩的话可能会被枪决。这就是第227号命令，发布于7月28日。有趣的是，这道命令从未通过任何苏联媒体或红军媒体公开发布过。它是被打印成小册子，然后宣读给部队、军官和士兵听的。而且它主要针对的是军官阶层，因为它在说，你们这些家伙需要表现出更多骨气，我们绝不再后撤，任何关键设施都必须坚守
to the last man. And to back that up, he then instigated what's now famous as these blocking detachments. There weren't a lot of units, roughly a division of 15,000 to 20,000 men. You'd probably have 500 military police acting as their blocking detachments. But what they did do was situate themselves in key transport areas and make sure they're checking troops. Where are you going? What are you doing? And then the penal battalions. And they had been around the previous year, again, but they'd been created on the hoof during the days of Barbarossa when it was panic. Whereas in the summer of 42 and order 227, it was more systematic. So it was specifically planned that we will create these penal battalions. And again, they were predominantly staffed by
到最后一兵一卒。为了支持这一点，他随后发起设立了现在闻名遐迩的“督战队”。这些部队数量并不多，大约只有一个师，有1.5万到2万名士兵。你大概会有500名宪兵充当督战队。但他们的确会驻扎在交通要道，并负责盘查军队。你们要去哪里？你们在干什么？接着就是惩戒营。前一年其实也出现过惩戒营，但在巴巴罗萨行动初期那种惊慌失措的日子里，它们是仓促组建的。相比之下，在42年夏天和第227号命令下达时，这就变得更有系统性了。所以，建立这些惩戒营是经过专门计划的。同样地，它们的成员主要由
NCOs and officers because they were the ones that were deemed to be lacking this moral fibre and backbone to actually put up a fight. So Ian, basically the Red Army know that they've got to make a stand in Stalingrad. They have no choice. Just to nail this down, why did the Germans go into Stalingrad? Are they sucked in? Are they going in there because Hitler's told them to? Are they going in there because they think it will be a walkover? Why the germans go into the city by the time they reach there in late august early september they are under orders now to take the city and again hitler's been uh is famous for saying that the whole male population would be exterminated because obviously it's called stalingrad it's a nest of bolshevism so that that's very roman exactly it's very carthage, isn't it? And the city would be leveled. So by then it was definitely,
士官和军官组成，因为他们被认为缺乏这种道德骨气和斗志来真正进行战斗。所以，伊安，基本上红军知道他们必须在斯大林格勒背水一战。他们别无选择。为了彻底弄明白这一点，德国人为什么要进攻斯大林格勒？他们是被拖入泥潭的吗？他们去那里是因为希特勒命令他们这么做吗？他们去那里是因为他们以为会是一场轻松的胜利吗？德国人为什么会在8月下旬到9月上旬到达该市时进入这座城市？他们当时已经接到必须攻占该城的命令，而且希特勒再次因扬言要消灭全体男性人口而闻名，因为显而易见，这座城市叫斯大林格勒，它是布尔什维克的巢穴，所以这非常罗马化
we are going into the city. You're right in terms of, yes, they were sucked in. But again, they were thinking that this is going to be the same as the fighting that they had the previous year in Kiev. That summer they take in Voronezh and Rostov as in there it would be a fight a bitter fight but they they take the city in the week the bank of the river was covered in dead fish mixed with human heads arms and legs all lying on the beach they were the remains of people who had been being evacuated across the Volga when they were bombed and Ian the German attack begins with this horrendous bombing. And you say that it's it kind of the casualties are on such a high scale that only Hiroshima exceeds them. Yeah. Which is kind of mind blowing.
完全就像迦太基一样，不是吗？这座城市将被夷为平地。所以到那时，毫无疑问，我们要攻入这座城市。从某种角度来说你是对的，他们确实被拖进去了。但他们当时认为，这会和他们前一年在基辅的战斗一样。那个夏天他们占领了沃罗涅日和罗斯托夫，他们觉得那会是一场恶战，但他们会在一周内拿下这座城市。河岸上到处都是死鱼，混杂着人类的头颅、手臂和腿，全都横陈在海滩上。这些都是人们在横渡伏尔加河撤离时遭到轰炸后的残骸。伊安，德军的进攻始于这场惨绝人寰的轰炸。你说这种轰炸造成的伤亡规模极大，只有广岛能超过它。这简直太震撼了。
Well, again, that gets back to my very first point about trying to dig deep enough to see if it's actually true. I'm not I'm not disputing that thousands were killed so from august 23rd onwards that's where the Luftwaffe are operating ahead of the advancing uh armor of of paulus's sixth army and the infantry bringing up the rear and it's a terror bombing campaign as as has been seen in Western Europe. So Rotterdam, that kind of thing, where they're literally blitzing the city. Indiscriminate bombing of civilians. And it was wave after wave of unmolested Luftwaffe bombers and dive bombers, especially, that had free reign across the city. The Soviet Air Force had pretty much been shot out to the sky during that advance that summer.
嗯，这又回到了我的第一个观点，那就是试图深入挖掘，看看这是否真的是事实。我并不是在争论成千上万的人丧生。因此，从8月23日开始，德国空军开始在保卢斯第六装甲集群推进的前方展开行动，步兵则在后面跟进，这是一场正如在西欧所看到的那样的恐怖轰炸行动。就像鹿特丹那样，他们对城市进行地毯式轰炸。对平民进行无差别的轰炸。这是一波又一波畅通无阻的德国空军轰炸机，特别是俯冲轰炸机，它们在城市上空拥有绝对制空权。那个夏天的推进过程中，苏联空军基本上已经被打出了天空。
They would get stronger. So these civilians are sitting ducks? They are. Well, the city had been swollen by double its size by the time the Germans actually arrived. So this city of 450,000 was well over 800,000 by the time of the bombings. There hadn't been that much planning
它们会变得更强大。所以这些平民就成了任人宰割的羔羊？确实如此。嗯，当德国人真正到达时，这座城市的人口已经比平时暴增了一倍。因此，在轰炸发生时，这座原本拥有45万人口的城市已经远远超过了80万人。此前并没有太多的规划
to have any air raid shelters built. For the previous two months, once Case Blue was underway and there was a fear of they could push to the Volga and Stalingrad, the civic leaders had turfed out the population to build these concentric circles of defensive rings that went out at least 50 to 60 to 70 kilometres outside of the city and stretched for hundreds of miles and had gun emplacements and everything else.
来修建任何防空洞。在过去的两个月里，一旦蓝色方案展开，人们担心他们会推进到伏尔加河和斯大林格勒，市民领袖们就把居民赶出去，修筑这些同心圆防线，一直延伸到距离市区至少50、60到70公里远的地方，绵延数百英里，配备了炮兵阵地和其他一切设施。
And they had spent no time on developing any kind of air shelters that were strong enough to withstand this kind of bombing. There were some buildings and there would be later used for the house-to-house fighting that had cellars that were reinforced with concrete, but you can't get 800,000 civilians in those kinds of places. There weren't enough of them. And Stalin had forbidden civilians to leave Stalingrad,'t he yes because he wanted the the army the the retreating 62nd army and 64th army that had been out in the steppe trying to prevent Paulus reaching the city were now the the remnants of them and whatever artillery and
而且他们没有花任何时间来开发任何足以经受这种轰炸的防空洞。有一些建筑物——后来将被用于巷战——它们的地下室用混凝土加固了，但你无法把80万平民塞进那种地方。数量根本不够。斯大林曾禁止平民离开斯大林格勒，不是吗？是的，因为他希望军队——那些在草原上试图阻止保卢斯到达城市的、正在撤退的第62集团军和第64集团军的残余部队，以及他们剩下的任何火炮和
tanks they had left were now ensconced in the city waiting for the final onslaught it was deemed that they'd fight for a live city better than they would for a dead one yeah so let's move through the the narrative a bit so the the bombing starts on the 23rd of august um two horrendous days of just just absolute kind of carpet bombing and quite quickly the german troops reached the outskirts and then the 3rd of september so that's what about 10 days later and then about a week after that the first sixth army units reach the volga river and split yeah the so at that point you would think well the kind of game is up the the battle is lost on the 12th of september there's an interesting moment because that's the point at which um the 62nd army soviet army gets a new commander vasily chuikov who's and and his story is the one
坦克——现在都隐蔽在城市里，等待着最后的总攻。人们认为，为一座活着的城市战斗，总比为一座死去的城市战斗要好。是的。那么让我们稍微推进一下叙事，轰炸从8月23日开始，经历了两天惨绝人寰的地毯式轰炸，很快德军就推进到了市郊，接着是9月3日，也就是大约10天后，大约一周后，第六集团军的第一批部队抵达了伏尔加河并将其切断。是的，所以在那个时候，你会觉得大势已去，这场战斗已经失败了。9月12日发生了一个有趣的时刻，因为那是第62集团军——苏联军队——拥有了一位新指挥官瓦西里·崔可夫的时刻，他的故事就是
that you start your book with with his funeral because he really is the preeminent hero of stalingrad isn't he do you want to tell us a little bit about who he is yeah so he's uh died in the war communist uh he'd fought in the uh the r Civil War. He's one of several children. He was born and raised in a village outside of Moscow. At age of 18, during the Russian Civil War, he commanded his own horseback regiment at 18. He won several battles during, as Anthony Beevor says in his new book, a very, very bloody civil war. And he survived that as well. And then he joined full time into the Red Army itself and went through the various ranks, more training. He'd been a very good linguist, spoke fluent Chinese as well.
你书的开篇所讲述的，从他的葬礼开始，因为他确实是斯大林格勒最杰出的英雄，不是吗？你想给我们讲讲他是谁吗？好的，他在战争中去世，是一名共产主义者，曾在俄国内战中战斗过。他是几个孩子之一。他在莫斯科郊外的一个村庄出生长大。在18岁时，即俄国内战期间，他年仅18岁就指挥了自己的骑兵团。正如安东尼·比弗在他的新书中提到的那样，在一次非常非常血腥的内战中，他赢得了几场战役。他也从那场战争中幸存了下来。然后他全职加入了红军，历经不同的军衔，接受了更多的培训。他是一位非常优秀的语言学家，也能说一口流利的汉语。
So he was a military attaché to China in the 1930s. And I suppose you could say he was lucky. He wasn't in charge of any formation on the Western European Russian side when Barbarossa struck. So he was one of the ones that Stalin and the Stavka, his military command, turned to parachute in to take over a command by the spring of 1942. And he's kind of a hard man, isn't he? Ruthless, Chuikov. But of his time.
所以在20世纪30年代，他是驻中国的军事武官。我想你可以说他很幸运。当巴巴罗萨爆发时，他并不负责西欧俄罗斯一侧的任何部队。因此，到1942年春天，他是斯大林和最高统帅部（他的军事指挥部）转而空降去接管指挥权的其中一人。他是一个强硬的人，不是吗？崔可夫冷酷无情。但也是那个时代的人。
I mean, he's a committed communist of that era, so he wouldn't think twice. And there are reports, recorded reports of him shooting officers he deemed not to be doing their duty. Well, that would put them on their guard. Point blank in the head in front of the troops. That's like our podcast producer. That's his um
我的意思是，他是那个时代坚定的共产主义者，所以他不会有任何迟疑。有记录显示，他枪决了他认为没有履行职责的军官。嗯，那会让他们保持警惕。当着部队的面直接朝头部开枪。这就像我们的节目制作人。那是他的……
so so is it true cough who comes up with the idea for the kind of is for sort of that they'll defend it house to house they're up close isn't it yeah up close sort of these incredibly intimate kind of almost individual um sort of gunfights rather rather than mass sort of pitched battles in the city streets it's going to be room to room it's kind of floor to floor all that stuff at the beginning when he took over the command he was under orders from uh yeromenko who was his overall commander he was in charge of operations throughout the city and out to the east and nikita khrushchev who was the political commissar there who was over watching everything on stalin's behalf and his his job description was you'll you'll defend the city or die in the attempt and he repeated that mantra and they said great you you understand your orders uh and off he went and
所以，是崔可夫想出了这种想法，或者说他们将逐屋防守，进行近距离战斗，对吧？近距离的，这种令人难以置信的、几乎是个人性质的枪战，而不是在城市街道上的大规模阵地战。这将是逐室进行的，几乎是逐层进行的。一开始，当他接管指挥权时，他奉叶廖缅科的命令，叶廖缅科是他的最高指挥官，负责整个城市以及向东的行动；还有尼基塔·赫鲁晓夫，他是那里的政治委员，代表斯大林监督一切。他的职责描述是：你要么守住这座城市，要么在战斗中牺牲。他重复了这句座右铭，他们说：很好，你理解你的命令，然后他就出发了，并
yes i mean it he put the backbone into the army he clung on to what was a remorseless advance into the city by the German troops with their way paved by just incredibly violent and powerful aerial assaults. And as I said before, this was unmolested. They had uncontested skies. They could pick and choose when and where they were going to dive bomb or carpet bomb. And they had to put up with this. And then once the Germans were moving in, they then had their artillery. And before fresh troops could come online, what was he to do?
是的，我的意思是，他给军队注入了骨气。他顽强抵抗德军对这座城市毫不留情的推进，德军的道路是由极其暴力和强大的空袭铺平的。正如我之前所说，这是毫无阻碍的。他们拥有不受挑战的制空权。他们可以挑选俯冲轰炸或地毯式轰炸的时间和地点。苏军不得不忍受这一切。一旦德国人攻入城内，他们就有了火炮。在生力军加入之前，他能做什么？
What was his only option? And the thing is, yes, I'm now living and fighting in a destroyed city. Perfect ambush material. Because, Ian, isn't that, I mean, that is the great, almost discovery, isn't it? People hadn't really realised this before, that actually a city that's been flattened by aerial bombardment, you don't just have to surrender it, it actually provides a perfect place with which to resist an incoming army. And that's obviously something that people since the Second World War have absolutely understood. But is it Stalingrad that first kind of puts that to the test, that these are the first people really to discover this?
他唯一的选择是什么？问题是，是的，我现在在一个被毁的城市里生活和战斗。完美的伏击材料。因为，伊安，难道那不是一个伟大的、几乎是突破性的发现吗？人们以前并没有真正意识到这一点，实际上，被空中轰炸夷为平地的城市，你不仅仅只能选择投降，它实际上为抵抗来犯之敌提供了完美的场所。这显然是二战以来人们绝对理解的事情。但斯大林格勒是第一个接受这种考验的地方吗？这些人真的是第一批发现这一点的人吗？
Yeah, in a mass form, yes. I mean, it's the first time that there's actual official orders of this is how we're going to defend what territory we're clinging on to. So they were only 300, 400 metres away from the Volga to their backs. The bulk of the city, especially in the center and the south, south had been captured. In the center, they were almost pushed into the river. They were clinging on.
是的，以一种大规模的形式，确实如此。我的意思是，这是第一次有官方命令指示我们将如何保卫我们死死坚守的领土。因此，他们距离身后的伏尔加河只有300到400米。城市的大部分，尤其是中部和南部，都已经沦陷。在市中心，他们几乎被逼到河里。他们还在死死支撑。
And as you say, if you've got a well-armed defensive unit, primarily with machine guns and submachine guns, the very famous PPSH-40 submachine gun, they use that like confetti for the Soviet troops there. It's hard to advance against that. Yes, you'll have aerial and artillery bombardments to pave your way. But as I said before, a lot of the buildings in the center of the city and in the north, the factory district, they had a lot of reinforced concrete bunkers uh or cellars i should say that they turned into bunkers and some of these famous buildings and one of which we'll talk about
正如你所说，如果你有一支武装精良的防御部队，主要装备机枪和冲锋枪，也就是非常著名的PPSH-40冲锋枪，苏联士兵使用它们就像抛洒彩纸一样。要想在这种火力下推进是很艰难的。是的，你们会有空袭和炮火轰炸来为你们开路。但正如我之前所说，市中心和北部工厂区的许多建筑都有很多钢筋混凝土掩体——或者我应该说地下室——他们把这些地下室改造成了掩体，其中一些著名的建筑，我们将讨论其中之一
uh that survived uh they're obviously bombed out but they could still be turned into mini fortresses so like in mario pole yeah exactly and so by about mid-september i suppose the two sides of it's not quite a stalemate i suppose suppose, but they are fighting now hand to hand. It's clear that the Germans aren't just going to sweep to the Volga and basically push the Russians into the river, partly because the Russians are, they're ferried men across the Volga, haven't they? So most famously, Major General Rodintsev,
幸存下来的建筑——它们显然被炸毁了，但仍然可以被改造成迷你堡垒。就像在马里乌波尔一样，是的，完全是这样。所以到9月中旬左右，我想双方并不是陷入了完全的僵局，但他们现在正在进行肉搏战。很明显，德国人不会只是横扫伏尔加河，基本上把俄国人推到河里，部分原因在于俄国人正在用船只将士兵运过伏尔加河，对吧？其中最著名的就是少将罗季姆采夫，
you have an amazing sort of set piece in your book about him, his men, his guards unit, kind of going across and basically getting a kind of foothold. So even at that stage, do you think Paulus and the 6th Army commanders are thinking, oh, this hasn't worked out as we thought, this is going to be really, really tough? Or do they still think, you know, give it a couple of weeks, we will finish the job?
你的书中有一个关于他、他的部下以及他的近卫军部队过河并基本上建立了一个立足点的精彩片段。所以即使在那个阶段，你认为保卢斯和第六集团军的指挥官们在想，哦，这没有像我们想象的那样奏效，这将是非常非常艰难的？还是他们仍然认为，给它几周时间，我们就会完成任务？
Well, no, definitely on the ground, regimental officers, divisional officers, and even as far up as Paulus himself talking to various reporters that might drop into his HQ, were openly questioning how much could they suffer, how many casualties could they take in this, what was turning into a bit of a meat grinder, where they were losing whole units in one operation in a day, and how tenacious the Soviet defence were. And as you say, even though they could bomb the Volga
嗯，不，绝对是在地面上，团级军官、师级军官，甚至一直到保卢斯本人，在与可能造访他指挥部的各种记者交谈时，都在公开质疑他们能承受多少痛苦，在这场正在变成绞肉机的战斗中他们能承受多少伤亡，他们在一次行动中就在一天之内损失了整支部队，以及苏联的防御是多么顽强。正如你所说，尽管他们可以用火炮和空袭轰炸伏尔加河
with artillery and aerial assaults, the Russians were still managing to keep alive the supply routes that were trickling through across from the eastern shore, where a lot of their landing platforms were camouflaged, or if they were destroyed, they were rebuilt overnight, and they were sending them across and like you said with redemptive again what was happening were now the russian uh stalin in moscow with his commanders knew that the main thrust of hitler's summer campaign was clearly now the south they slowly started to move the the armies and divisions that had been coalesced around moscow to move down south and these were coming in echelon down to the south. So they could only be put in piecemeal as they arrived. And that's what happened with Radimtsev's 13th Guards Rifle Division. He was just one of many divisions that were fed into the maelstrom as they literally arrived. I mean, within 24 hours of them landing or finishing their forced march to the banks,
俄国人仍然设法维持了从东岸穿过来的微弱补给线，他们的大多数登陆平台都进行了伪装，如果被毁，他们就会连夜重建，并将他们运送过来。就像你刚才说的罗季姆采夫一样，当时发生的事情是，莫斯科的斯大林和他的指挥官们知道希特勒夏季战役的主攻方向显然现在是南部。他们开始慢慢调动在莫斯科周围集结的军队和师，向南移动，这些部队以梯队形式向南开进。因此，他们只能在到达时零星地投入战斗。罗季姆采夫的第13近卫步兵师就是这样情况。随着他们的陆续抵达，他只是被投入这个巨大漩涡的众多师之一。我的意思是，在他们登陆或完成强行军到达河岸后的24小时内，
they were rearmed uh the various stories that you see with jude law the jude laws in the 13th guards i was just thinking about that the film enemy at the gates when it begins they arrive at the volga and there's this incredible set piece where they're you know and they have nothing yeah and then that and that's exactly how it happened is it they you just arrive arrive by train or whatever, or by truck, and you'd just be thrown across the river. Off you go into the meat grinder. Yeah, but obviously there was method in their madness.
他们重新武装了自己……你在裘德·洛主演的电影《兵临城下》中看到的各种场景，第13近卫军里也有裘德·洛……我刚才就在想那部电影，当它开始时，他们抵达了伏尔加河，这是一个令人难以置信的场景，他们一无所有……然后，这完全就是当时发生的情况，对吧？你只是坐火车或者乘卡车到达，然后你就会被扔过河去。直接投入绞肉机。是的，但显然他们的疯狂行为中是有章可法的。
They're putting them into the weak points where they know the Germans are about to break through, and it's just the case. And Zhukov was very much like this. He wasn't a delicate, or you could call an artistic, innovative combat commander. Very sledgehammer. Was it he who said, well, there's no scope for Napoleonic? Absolutely.
他们把他们投入到他们知道德国人即将突破的薄弱环节，情况就是这样。朱可夫非常符合这种风格。他不是一个细腻的，或者你可以称之为艺术性的、创新的作战指挥官。非常像大锤。是不是他说过，拿破仑式的战术没有发挥的空间？绝对是这样的。
You know, you just go in there and you stand and you shoot. Yeah. And in some ways, later historians, especially over the last 10 to 15 years, have been more critical of his performance, as in it was very unsophisticated and he literally just wanted to bleed the Germans dry. And he did that. Time is blood. That's his famous quote. And time also means that it's starting to get colder. Yep.
你知道，你只要冲进去，站在那里开枪就行了。是的。从某些方面来说，后来的历史学家，特别是过去10到15年里，对他的表现更加持批评态度，认为这非常简单粗暴，他字面意思上就是想让德国人流尽最后一滴血。他也确实做到了。“时间就是鲜血。”这是他的名言。时间也意味着天气开始变冷了。是的。
So it's starting to snow. It's starting to freeze. The Germans don't have the right coats. They don't have the right shoes. Tom's always anxious about footwear freeze. The Germans don't have the right coats. They don't have the right shoes. Tom's always anxious about footwear. Yeah, they don't have the right shoes, but the Russians do. So winter is coming
所以开始下雪了。开始结冰了。德国人没有合适的大衣。他们没有合适的鞋子。汤姆总是担心鞋子的保暖问题。德国人没有合适的大衣。他们没有合适的鞋子。汤姆总是担心鞋子的保暖问题。是的，他们没有合适的鞋子，但俄国人有。所以冬天要来了
and this seems the perfect place to take a break. So in the next episode, Ian will be joining us again and we will look at, let's look at Pavlov and his house, because that's a key part of the story that we haven't touched on yet. And winter comes and the end of the battle and its enduring significance. So thank you to Ian and we will see you all next time for more Stalingrad.
这似乎是休息的绝佳时机。所以在下一集中，伊安将再次加入我们，我们将探讨巴甫洛夫和他的房子，因为这是我们尚未涉及的故事的关键部分。冬天来了，战役结束了，它具有持久的意义。所以感谢伊安，我们下次再见，了解更多关于斯大林格勒的故事。
Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听独家剧集、提前收听、无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。